Pessoal, será que essas cúrcumas
compradas em pó nos mercados tem
poderfatório? Pergunta que eu recebi de
um seguidor. Olha só, pessoal, essa
pergunta do nosso seguidor me fez
lembrar de uma situação que aconteceu
comigo outro dia no mercado. Eu tava lá
na prateleira dos temperos, fui
reconhecido, olhando aqueles potinhos de
cúcuma. Uma senhora do meu lado
perguntou: "Doutor, esse açafrãozinho aí
resolve mesmo inflamação ou é conversa
fiada?" Sabe que essa é uma dúvida que
muita gente tem, né? Então vamos bater
um papo sobre isso hoje. A cúrcuma, que
muitos conhecem como açafrão da terra,
não confunda com açafrão verdadeiro que
custa uma fortuna, é aquele pozinho
amarelo dourado que a gente compra no
supermercado. O que dá esse poder
anti-inflamatório para ela é um composto
chamado curcumina. É tipo assim, imagina
que a cúrcuma é o carro e a curcumina é
o motor. Sem o motor, o carro não anda
muito longe. Concorda comigo? Agora vem
um problema, pessoal. Quando a gente
analisa esses pos de cúrcuma vendidos
nos mercados brasileiros, a quantidade
de cúrcumina varia muito. Tem produto
com 0,06%
e outros com até 2%. Para vocês terem
uma ideia, como comprar um suco de
laranja que pode ter de uma gota até
meio copo de laranja de verdade,
complicado, né? A maioria dos produtos
aqui do Brasil tem menos de 1% de
curcumina. E é pouco, sim, é pouco.
Principalmente quando comparamos com os
extratos padronizados que chegam até 95%
de curcumina. Mas calma, não precisa
jogar fora aquele potinho de cúrcuma que
você tem em casa. A cucumina, mesmo em
pequenas quantidades, tem sim efeito
antiinflamatório. Ela age em várias vias
do nosso corpo. NFK beta, MK, JK, SAT.
Tá bom? Não vou ficar falando grego para
vocês. O que importa é que ela bloquee a
produção de substâncias inflamatórias no
nosso organismo. O problema é que para
ter um efeito terapêutico potente, tipo
para tratar artrite ou dores crônicas, a
quantidade que a gente consegue com a
cúrcuma do mercado é um café pequeno.
OK? Agora eu vou dar uma dica de ouro
para vocês. E olha que isso é ciência
pura, sabe? A pimenta preta, a pimenta
do reino que tá aí na sua cozinha. Então
ela tem um composto chamado piperina,
que é tipo um personal trainer pra
cucumina. Estudos mostram que quando
você combina a cúrcuma com uma pitadinha
da peta do reino, a absorção da cucumina
aumenta em até 2.000%. Isso mesmo que
vocês ouviram, 2000%. É como se você
transformasse aquela gotinha de suco de
laranja em 2 L. Impressionante, né? Tem
mais um truque que funciona muito bem. A
curcumina é lipossolúvel, ou seja, ela
gosta de gordura. Então, quando você usa
cúrcuma, combina com um fio de a de
oliva, com abacate ou até com leite de
coco. Isso ajuda muito na absorção. E é
por isso que na culinária indiana eles
sempre usam cúma com gui, que é a
manteiga clarificada. Esses caras sabem
das coisas há milhares de anos. Mas
vamos ser honestos aqui, pessoal. Se
você tá procurando um efeito
antiinflamatório mais potente, como
remédio mesmo, para tratar uma condição
específica, provavelmente vai precisar
de suplementos padronizados de
curcumina.
É que para conseguir uma dose
terapêutica, só com a cúrcuma em pó,
você teria que comer colheradas e
colheradas e coleradas por dia e aí o
seu arroz ia ficar mais amarelo que o
uniforme da seleção brasileira.
A nanotecnologia também tá entrando
nessa jogada. Estão disponíveis já no
mercado da farmácia magistral de
manipulação, nanformulações de cucumina
que aumenta a absorção em várias vezes.
É o futuro que já chegou. Então, procure
sempre o suplemento de nanoformulação,
de nanomicelas, que vai aumentar muita
absorção do produto e vai ter uma ação
de inflamatória muito melhor. Então,
respondendo a pergunta do nosso
seguidor, sim, a cúrcuma em pó do
mercado tem poder antiflamatório, mas é
um poder modesto. É como tomar um
anflamatório bem fraquinho, sabe? Serve
para manutenção da saúde, para dar
aquela ajudinha no dia a dia, mas não é
aquela bomba antifamatória que algumas
pessoas esperam. Para efeitos mais
potentes, o ideal é partir paraos
suplementos padronizados e com
nanotecnologia
ou pelo menos caprichar na pimenta do
reino e no azeite quando usar a cúrcuma.
O legal é que dá para incorporar a
cúrcuma na rotina de um jeito gostoso.
Faz aí um golden milk com leite de coco,
cúrcuma, pimenta do reino e um pouquinho
de mel. Ou coloca no frango, no arroz.
os legumes, vai criando hábito. Aquela
história de grão em grão a galinha enche
o papo. No caso, de pitada em pitada, a
gente vai combatendo a inflamação.
Pessoal, o importante é entender que não
existe bala de prata na medicina. A
cúrcuma é mais uma ferramenta no nosso
arsenal antiflamatório junto com
alimentação equilibrada, exercício, sono
adequado e reparador e controle
estresse. Ela faz a diferença sim, é o
conjunto da obra que importa. E olha,
pelo preço que custa um potinho de
cúrcuma no mercado, vale a pena incluir
na sua dieta do dia a dia para
prevenção. Só não esquece de adicionar a
pimenta do reino, ok? Essa dupla é tipo
Batman Robin. Funciona muito melhor
junta. Yeah.